[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur le Podcast un
cimenterme le podcast où on parle avec
des personnes expertes de la
vulgarisation scientifique aujourd'hui
on parle beaucoup de la forme de rendre
une communication scientifique un petit
peu plus fun et pour ça on accueille
celle qui fait ça à chacune de ces
productions Valentine de sciences du
comptoir si vous ne la connaissez pas
déjà je vous invite à aller voir au
moins une de ces vidéos avant de
commencer le podcast vous comprendrez
mieux son approche dans la vie a fait
plein de choses différentes elle est un
petit peu journaliste elle enseigne
aussi un vulgarisation spécifiquement
sur le web pour des futurs journalistes
et elle est vidéaste de sa propre chaîne
et pour d'autres médias mais partout où
qu'elle aille on retrouve sa patte où
elle tente d'adoucir des propos
scientifiques en ajoutant des blagues
mais comment doser à quel moment est-ce
qu'on fait trop de blagues est-ce que
c'est possible d'avoir trop de blagues
au moment où on enregistre le podcast on
est à Avignon septembre 2022 dans une
location où l'éclairage est naturel et
ça se voit pour les personnes qui vont
nous suivre en vidéo et tout de suite je
laisse la parole à Valentine où on
attaque avec cette question de l'humour
et du spectacle et je n'en dis pas plus
je lui laisse la parole puisqu'elle en
parle en sédentaire c'est moi ça un jour
faire de du spectacle
c'est comme un substrat oui voilà c'est
un support pour dire des conneries quoi
enfin faire des blagues pas dire
parce que c'est ça ton objectif
principal c'est de faire rire alors
c'est c'est un peu deux objectifs quoi
genre vulgariser enfin il y en a trois
vulgariser donc faire passer des infos
scientifiques faire rigoler et en même
temps essayer de dérider l'image qu'on
peut avoir de la géologie parce que à la
base elle est pas pas bien servi
non c'est pour rigoler mais peut-être
que un jour non mais genre si je suis un
jour invite à faire une conférence genre
un festival ou quoi plutôt que de faire
une conférence faire un truc un peu mis
slender mais tu vois ça ça me plairait
bien et est-ce que tu as pas
l'impression que le en faisant autant
d'humour tu réduis la vulgarisation et
en faisant la vulgarisation tu aurais dû
l'humour genre est-ce que c'est est-ce
que c'est des vases qui sont pas
communicants ou est-ce que tu arrives à
les comment est-ce que tu arrives à
doser ça ouais c'est un dosage que j'ai
pas encore trouvé et du coup je teste
parce que j'étais un peu timide au début
et à chaque vidéo j'essaie d'en mettre
un peu plus et en général j'ai des bons
retours jusqu'à une vidéo j'en ai mis
vraiment beaucoup trop en fait qui était
pour le vortex et donc en fait je vais
pas mal de retour en me disant là il y a
trop de blagues s'il te plaît parce que
ça coupe l'information en fait donc
c'est un équilibre à trouver est-ce que
ça te frustre de devoir réduire le temps
de blagues pour revenir faire plus
non pas forcément mais c'est juste ça me
frustre de pas de pas arriver à deviner
on avance ce qui convient pour servir
l'information et pour faire un contenu
qui soit à la fois divertissant et
informatif est-ce que c'est tu
t'entraînes avant de faire tes vidéos
c'est à dire je m'en sers
quand tu regardes le monde des
humoristes ils vont tester leur blague
ah oui tu vois et donc toi comme tu mets
tellement d'humour c'est sûr que comme
tu as pas de test de blagues tu sais pas
non je teste rien tu testes rien parce
que en vigueur on peut pas tester de
toute façon en vidéo c'est difficile non
non mais du coup c'est un test et puis
je vois c'est la vidéo c'est le test
puis je vois en fonction des
commentaires ou des retours IRL qu'on
peut me faire c'est là que j'essaye
d'ajuster mais d'une vidéo sur l'autre
tu peux pas ajuster pour celle d'avant
quoi non bien sûr est-ce que donc dans
la vidéo du vortex que tu as fait elle
était sur quoi celle-là celle-là c'était
sur la fusion nucléaire donc énorme
sujet plein de trucs à dire et pas
besoin de blagues en vrai et donc là
est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui que
tu vas essayer de réduire le nombre de
pour revenir à ton niveau juste avant ou
est-ce que tu veux tu veux rester là
parce que des fois tu sais on peut aussi
choisir de ne pas suivre le public ouais
on peut bah alors c'est un peu délicat
parce que là en question enfin là
c'était une vidéo qui était pas pour ma
chaîne c'était pour le vortex et tout ça
enfin c'est j'engage pas mal de monde
donc là je vais essayer de me calmer un
peu mais sur ma chaîne je pense que Yolo
je vais continuer à faire des blagues et
puis voilà quoi parce que c'est ça qui
te plaît ouais c'est ça mais par contre
il y a blague et blague c'est à dire que
au début j'allais beaucoup dans la
provoc spécialement des blagues
connotées politiquement d'un côté comme
de l'autre et voilà pour faire agir et
plus ça va que je me dis que c'est pas
utile et que c'est vraiment la blague
facile ça et que du coup j'essaie de
trouver un peu autre chose quoi quand tu
dis que tu essayes de trouver autre
chose c'est c'est quoi cette autre chose
cette autre chose c'est je sais pas
essayer de sortir des des lieux communs
des blagues sur je n'ose pas citer parce
que tu vas être démonétisé mais des
trucs horribles
voilà évitez les blagues sur les
minorités au sens large tu vois ce genre
de choses et essayer de je sais pas j'en
fais des blagues un peu plus de niche
donc faire des trucs sur les Bretons les
Bretons ils prennent bien les blagues il
y a pas de problème donc tu vois c'est
ça c'est minorité mais ils sont ils sont
cools et donc c'est parce que c'est
horrible parce que je viens de dire
ça trop facile de faire des blagues sur
les minorités ou c'est parce que même
toi ça te fait plus rien bah il y a un
peu les deux en vrai d'une part parce
que je me rends compte que derrière la
blague ça peut faire passer un message
que j'ai pas du tout envie de faire
passer tu vois et que dans ma tête c'est
ironique mais certaines personnes
prendre ça au premier degré je veux
surtout pas faire passer ce genre de
message parce que je cautionne pas quoi
et puis d'autre part parce que c'est vu
et revu et que bon je suis pas
Jean-Marie Bigard quoi non et tant mieux
oui c'est pas plus mal quelque part
c'est bien qu'il y en a un voilà et puis
après on ajoute de la diversité c'est ça
chacun sa niche écologique exactement et
donc toi le thème que tu veux gagner de
plus c'est la géologie ouais c'est parce
que tu es formé en géologie là-bas oui
j'ai une licence donc petite formation
c'est pas donc trois ans après la fac
licence en sciences de la Terre et
l'environnement et voilà après j'ai
bifurqué en biologie parce que je suis
revenue scène d'esprit et
je suis revenu dans mon chemin mais oui
j'ai une petite formation en géologie
mais c'est surtout parce parce que je
suis journaliste scientifique qui est en
tant que ça je pense que je peux traiter
un peu tous les sujets qui m'intéressent
c'est que je auquel je peux trouver des
informations quoi et du coup comme la
géologie est un sujet qui m'intéresse je
me documente dessus mais voilà la
licence ça me fait une base quoi ok donc
licence de on va dire géologie pour
faire simple et master de bio c'est ça
master de bio évolutif et master en
journalisme scientifique derrière ok
c'est ça toi tu as bifurqué avant même
de travailler en sciences vers le
journalisme scientifique ok pourquoi
est-ce que tu as fait ce choix là c'est
ce que je voulais faire depuis le début
avant ouais c'est marrant de choix alors
non pourquoi bah c'est rare d'avoir des
journalistes qui sont d'abord en tout
cas qui voulaient être journaliste et
qui commence par une formation
scientifique non ah parce que je voulais
être journaliste scientifique et du coup
pour faire ça en gros on m'avait dit
c'était au lycée je me suis dit tiens je
vais faire ça et enfin non c'était pas
juste tiens je vais faire ça c'était une
longue recherche beaucoup enfin voilà et
en fait là on m'a dit et bah il faut
d'abord une formation en sciences quelle
que soit la science et après faire une
formation comp lémentaire en
communication en journaliste
scientifique et si et du coup là je me
suis dit bah j'ai au moins 50 devant moi
étudié la science de mon choix c'est
n'importe quoi je veux vraiment je peux
faire ce que je veux et j'ai choisi les
cailloux voilà
c'est bien les cailloux
ça ne râle pas en tout cas exactement il
y a pas beaucoup d'éthique aussi à gérer
sur les cailloux c'est assez pratique
puisque expérimenté à l'infini ok donc
journaliste me scientifique c'est ce que
tu veux faire dès le départ puis tu
exerces aujourd'hui un temps que
journaliste ou tu es entre guillemets
que vidéaste je suis plutôt vidéaste
mais après il y a des compétences que
j'ai acquises en tant que journaliste
dont je me sers là je suis aussi des
vidéos avec une
comme on dit un média en groupe de
presse qui s'appelle Milan Presse et du
coup à ce titre là je suis à la fois
vidéaste et un petit peu journaliste
dans ma tête
mais je suis quand même surtout vidéaste
et tu m'as dit qu'on commence ce podcast
que je le savais déjà que tu enseignes
aussi ouais et tu enseignes pas le
journaliste non qu'est-ce que tu
enseignes j'enseigne alors je connais
pas l'intitulé exact je me souviens plus
mais ils ont changé la maquette pas
longtemps mais en gros c'est la
vulgarisation sur le web OK et quelle
est la différence entre l'enseignement
que tu as reçu de journalistes qui est
donc quelque chose de très traditionnel
à la vulgarisation sur le web quelque
chose d'un petit peu moins traditionnel
ouais alors
ouais effectivement c'est marrant parce
que à mon époque on n'enseignait pas du
tout les réseaux sociaux tout ça c'est
vraiment nouveau mon époque je suis
sortie en 2017 donc en vrai c'était pas
si longtemps que ça mais ça va vite les
époques mais ouais j'ai dit et du coup
moi j'enseigne plus tout ce qui est sur
les réseaux sociaux justement donc pas
uniquement pas uniquement YouTube mais
d'ailleurs il y a un prof de vidéo qui
s'occupe de ça mais aussi bien je sais
pas Instagram Twitter enfin tout et la
différence je pense que le premier
réflexe que j'apprends aux élèves enfin
aux étudiants c'est à se détendre du
slip parce que vraiment ils apprennent
ils apprennent à écrire un article de
presse donc il y a plein plein de codes
en vrai il y a plein de trucs à prendre
des petites ficelles de on met tel plan
on utilise telle information enfin voilà
c'est vraiment très très carré et je
leur apprends à juste se détendre et je
sais pas genre faire des blagues s'ils
veulent faire des blagues ou mettre un
peu de poésie dans leurs articles s'ils
ont envie ce genre de choses et c'est un
truc que j'aurais bien voulu avoir à mon
époque parce que moi-même j'ai mis
longtemps à me détendre du slip j'ai dû
mettre 6 mois après la formation à me
dire bon bah c'est bon maintenant je
peux faire des blagues un peu glisser
une ou deux trucs un peu un peu rigolo
et voilà et donc ça j'ai eu des retours
dessus de mes élèves et ils m'ont dit
que ça leur servait beaucoup en fait et
du coup d'apprendre justement à souffler
un bon coup et à prendre du plaisir en
écrivant ses articles quoi parce qu'on
n'est pas on n'est pas l'AFP on fait pas
des dépêches on est là pour faire passer
une information mais en même temps si
c'est agréable à lire et à écrire tant
mieux quoi là on a pas dit c'est des
étudiants
quoi en master de journalisme
scientifique ok donc ils sont déjà dans
le journaliste et donc toi tu leur
montres sur le web donc tu disais amener
de la poésie pourquoi est-ce que ça
c'est pas possible un journaliste
traditionnel si je pensais pas possible
mais simplement en vrai on a tellement
peu d'heures de cours que il vaut mieux
apprendre d'abord les les bases et
savoir pouvoir être le plus polyvalent
possible donc si tu écris au Figaro ou
si tu écris pour la science il faut
avoir vraiment les bases pour pouvoir
écrire dans ces jours-là dans ces
journaux là ou même faire du
documentaire ou des trucs comme ça et du
coup le côté un peu on est rigolo et on
fait des trucs un peu à côté et ben je
comprends que ce soit pas une priorité
en tout cas à mon époque maintenant
c'est quand même un truc qui est quand
même vachement vu notamment dans mon
master mais il y a d'autres Masters qui
étudient quand même beaucoup beaucoup la
chose donc il y a aussi une évolution
des mentalités de ce côté là et c'est
quand même assez cool là tu as surtout
mis l'accins sur le fait que c'était se
détendre du slip que d'aller sur le web
est-ce qu'il y a il y a d'autres codes
que ça parce que tu es la poésie
l'humour mais ça c'est beaucoup sur la
forme est-ce que sur le le fond il y a
aussi il y a aussi quelque chose de
différent sur le fond je vois beaucoup
de similitudes en vrai donc je pense
c'est quand même beaucoup la même chose
y compris le fait que toi tu enseigne
dans tes vidéos aussi de la phrase
accroche avoir un plan structuré avoir
une idée machin truc c'est globalement
la même recette mais simplement la on
peut être beaucoup plus
détendu
ok donc c'est un cours plus de forme en
fait ouais que tu vas faire ok c'est ça
et les étudiants tu vois leur évolution
oui très clairement il y a un avant et
un après cet exercice ok vraiment et
puis et puis même le reste du temps en
fait il justement il commence à goûter
un peu je sais pas au format court en
vidéo par exemple ou je sais pas au
poste Instagram à Twitter ceux qui
découvre Twitter bon ça c'était plus
vrai il y a quelques années maintenant
c'est un peu c'est un peu moins la fête
mais à l'époque c'était cool et donc je
sais pas c'est il découvre un nouvel
univers et du coup c'est à eux de se
l'approprier mais ouais ils ont fait
leur premier pas et du coup ils ont
moins peur est-ce que tu penses que
parce que ce détendre du slip je pense
que c'est quelque chose qu'on ne voit
pas beaucoup dans les médias
traditionnels est-ce que tu penses que
du coup cette génération là de
journalistes va arriver avec des codes
de beaucoup plus détendu dans des
traditionnel est-ce que ça va leur
porter préjudice au contraire ça va les
aider je pense que ça va les aider et
j'espère pour eux qu'ils vont amener ça
dans les médias effectivement parce
qu'ils ont besoin de lumière et
on vient de perdre tout le soleil
c'était un ouais ils ont les médias ont
besoin d'un certain renouveau et en vrai
il y ait mais simplement c'est il arrive
souvent d'en bas donc c'est genre les
stagiaires qui arrivent en disant et on
pourrait faire ça on pourra faire ça et
puis les vieux boomers qui sont tout en
haut de la pyramide des fois ils ont pas
envie de se lancer sur Tik Tok par
exemple ou tu vois que tout un média se
lance sur un nouveau réseau social par
exemple ça demande énormément de temps
d'argent de d'investissement en tout
genre y compris de réfléchir à une
stratégie et tout et du coup les médias
sont ils ont une certaine inertie que
non pas par exemple toi et moi on décide
de faire un truc et puis on peut le
faire et puis voilà quoi ça prend pas
beaucoup de temps de décision il y a
aussi moins hiérarchie c'est-à-dire que
on est toutes les deux les bosses et
puis il y a zéro employés en dessous de
toute façon donc c'est facile de changer
les choses mais après si je peux quand
même ajouter un truc c'est que les
médias quand même ils arrivent à quand
même se rajeunir un peu il tente des
trucs sur les réseaux sociaux sur enfin
je vois le monde qui fait des vidéos
face cam parce que face cam d'ailleurs
fait tout faim il y a quand même des
médias qui font des trucs incroyables
mais on le voit dans ces dernières
années l'apparition de combiné de brut
tout ça qui sont des formats beaucoup
plus web et beaucoup plus jeune c'est
quand même c'est qu'on voit qu'il y a un
renouveau aussi de de leur côté je
discutais la semaine dernière avec
Pierre Kerner que tu connais qui
enseignes aussi la vulgarisation et lui
a des étudiants en biologie et il me
racontait la différence entre les
étudiants de licence et ses étudiants de
Master et comme ces étudiants de Master
ils avaient déjà
ils étaient déjà cadrés dans leur
cerveau ils savaient déjà comment faire
un rapport scientifique et c'était dur
de ramener leur créativité en tout cas
il fallait fallait faire une action pour
ramener leur créativité tandis que les
étudiants de licence au contraire
c'était la science qui pêchait un petit
peu et puis que là ils étaient
débordants de créativité est-ce que
c'est quelque chose que tu as remarqué
un manque de Cré dans les premiers dans
les tous premiers cours de la part des
étudiants Masters alors pas vraiment
parce que en fait c'est des étudiants
qui viennent pour faire ça et du coup
ils ont déjà envie ils ont déjà dans le
mindset comme on dit de faire ce genre
d'exercice donc là il y a pas trop de
problèmes mais après si tu prends genre
des doctorants ou des gens qui n'ont pas
l'habitude de faire ça et qui s'essaye à
la vulgarisation comme ça mais qui
veulent pas spécialement faire leur
métier effectivement je trouve beaucoup
plus cet état d'esprit de on essaye on
essaye mais c'est dur de sortir de
casser les codes de sortir de ce cadre
académique quoi
après c'est aussi que tu as des
étudiants journalistes donc forcément
c'est pas du tout la même le même état
d'esprit quand on arrive que quand on
est en bio comme les citoyens de Pierre
voilà du coup t'as jamais eu besoin de
développer des techniques pour réactiver
la créativité de tes études ça veut dire
parce qu'elle est déjà active quand ils
arrivent ouais non je juge je leur dis
feu vert allez-y quoi mais en gros non
non c'est eux qui arrivent avec leurs
idées c'est eux qui font ce qu'ils
veulent et puis si eux ils veulent faire
un truc très carré parce que c'est leur
façon de voir les choses je vais pas les
en empêcher pour autant quoi ah oui ok
donc tu leur apprends à descendre du
slip mais tu vas te t’empêche pas le
fait que ils ont le droit d'être carré
quand même rester coincé est-ce qu'on
sait c'est pas mon problème
chacun son balai chacun son balai donc
explique-moi comment ça se passe ton
cours comment ça se découpe qu'est-ce
qu'il y a comme apprentissage
explique-moi alors essentiellement on
s'assoit et on regarde des vidéos et on
écoute des potes non pas que mais ouais
donc il y a la première étape où je leur
dis d'écrire le fameux exercice de slip
c'est non pas écrire un article de
presse mais écrire un article de blog
alors je sais que ça se fait plus trop
les blogs aujourd'hui mais je trouve que
l'exercice est vraiment très intéressant
parce que les articles de blog ont une
certaine patte et c'est ça qui
m'intéressait là-dedans même si au final
bon ils vont pas se dire chouette je
sais écrire un article de blog c'est pas
c'est pas une fin quoi donc ça c'est la
première étape et puis après on découvre
les différentes les différentes
plateformes qui peut y avoir comment
s'approprier leur code quel type de
contenu va sur quoi enfin live twitch
aussi à la fin de l'année ou il y a des
petits enfin c'est eux qui le créent en
fait donc ils font la partie technique
et surtout le contenu moi c'est ça qui
m'intéresse donc ils peuvent réfléchir à
des jeux faut que ce soit interactif il
faut que qui regarde un peu ce qui se
fait déjà et puis qui réfléchissent en
fonction de comment est-ce que je peux
faire tout ça donc la dernière année ils
ont fait un quiz sur l'actualité
scientifique je crois ils ont fait un
truc aussi un peu genre photos mystère
donc qu'est-ce que c'est que ça et donc
soit c'était des photos en macros soit
c'était des trucs de très loin au
contraire soit enfin voilà puis je sais
plus voilà truc comme ça discuter un peu
des vidéos YouTube et un exercice que
j'aime bien faire du coup là il faut
qu'on s'arrange cette année avec le prof
de vidéo pour faire un truc en commun
c'est en fait ils ont un sujet qui
utilisent pour l'article de blog à la
base donc genre demande de bien fouiller
ce sujet là donc il part d'une étude
scientifique récente pour écrire leur
article et à partir de là c'est ce sujet
qui vont décliner sur tous les supports
donc Instagram Twitter machin truc et
aussi en vidéo YouTube et en vidéo ils
vont aussi tirer au sort une contrainte
qui est une contrainte de forme donc à
ce moment là soit ils peuvent écrire un
script avec leur sujet selon je sais pas
bon il y a évidemment le facecam mais il
y a aussi des trucs genre faire un haul
faire je sais pas genre morning routine
enfin plein de trucs tous les formats
qui peuvent imaginer sur YouTube donc on
y réfléchit ensemble on fait un petit
pot et comme ça il tire et ils écrivent
leur petit script et ils sont souvent
très contents et c'est drôle parce que
ça leur aide justement ça les aide à
sortir de de leur quotidien enfin de
leur petit chausson quoi c'est drôle
c'est le fait de tirer au sort des
contraintes c'est quelque chose que je
fais aussi ah oui
leur exercice final ils ont le droit de
ce mois c'est un cours qui a optionnel
ils sont pas obligé de le prendre et
donc je considère qu'encore optionnel
faut qu'ils aient du fun et que ce soit
positif pour eux et le final c'est eux
qui le choisissent les endroits de
choisir s'ils vont faire tel type
d'exercice ou tel type d'applique et un
des types c'est il va falloir que vous
vulgariez votre projet de recherche en 3
minutes mais vous connaissez pas les
contraintes et les contraintes on les
tire au sort donc ça peut être
une contrainte de public c'est le
premier ministre qui vient puis tu dois
faire passer ta recherche et montrer que
il y a besoin d'avoir du financement
un mot à caser du bruit dans la salle
pas de lumière ou tu vois ce grand chose
OK et donc il tire au sort au tout début
de la classe ils ont 15 minutes pour
réfléchir puis après au charbon c'est
génial
et on peut effrayant aussi un peu
effrayant c'est quand même un exercice
qui est pas facile mais c'est pas un
exercice que tu vois que tu peux louper
quoi parce que on est entre nous il y a
pas beaucoup de d'enjeux à ce moment-là
donc c'est juste si tu as envie de te
challenger c'est un coup d'exercice
c'est quel niveau ils sont tous un
doctorat il y en a quelques-uns qui sont
en maîtrise mais ils sont pas censés
prendre le cours quand ils sont maîtrise
mais il y a toujours des étudiants de
maîtrise je sais pas pourquoi mais c'est
pas assez pour les étudiants en doctorat
en tout cas donc leur objectif
enfin en tout cas l'objectif de ce cours
là c'est d'être capable de vulgariser sa
recherche parce que c'est censé être des
ateliers complémentaires doctorat donc
ils doivent les aider dans leur doctorat
c'est pas un cours vulgarisation
scientifique comme ça perdu et donc
c'est ça l'objectif à la fin et d'être
capable de numériser dans n'importe
quelle situation quoi c'est encore plus
difficile quand tu vulgaris tes propres
recher c'est plus difficile et plus
facile à la fois c'est plus facile parce
que tu as pas besoin de faire de la
libido de la biblio donc tu t'enlèves 20
ans c'est plus difficile parce que il y
a une prise de recul que tu dois faire
et qui est pas forcément évidente donc
c'est à la fois plus difficile et plus
facile donc ça dépend comment est-ce
qu'on voit les choses donc si on revient
à tes vidéos qui est ce pourquoi qui est
ton travail le plus exposé le plus
visible toi comment est-ce que tu
combats construire
une vidéo est-ce que tu construis
d'abord les blagues et après le contenu
comment est-ce que comment est-ce que tu
réfléchis à la construction de ta vidéo
alors en général il y a le contenu
d'abord même si pas toujours et après
dans un deuxième temps je réfléchis
d'une part à la mise en scène parce que
j'essaye de faire un effort de mise en
scène dans chaque vidéo même si ça se
voit pas voilà si quand même ça dépend
mais le plus flagrant c'était ma vidéo
sur la bouillabaisse où j'explique trois
familles de roche où je mangeais en fait
au fur et à mesure et ça tourne mal bref
et donc ça c'est une idée que j'avais
avant même le début de la chaîne genre
du temps de mon blog et tout bref et
donc ça pour donc le sujet d'abord la
mise en scène et puis les blagues ça
arrive au fur et à mesure et c'est même
des trucs que je peux avoir là comme ça
je note vite une blague que je peux
avoir et ça vient au fur et à mesure en
fait tu fais un une vraie construction
de vulgarisation puis les blagues c'est
que ça devient naturellement par-dessus
quasiment oui c'est ça ça vient
naturellement au moment où j'écris ou
alors au moment où je me documente sur
le sujet aussi quand je fais de la
biblio je me dis ah mais ça ça ressemble
en fait à un kebab et du coup je le mets
dans le script aussi pour pas oublier
que cette image là ça peut me servir et
donc ouais il y a plusieurs couches de
blagues et mais rarement je fais un truc
très sérieux et je repasse après pour
mettre des blagues c'est pas comme ça
que ça marche en fait ah ouais non c'est
pour ça que c'est vraiment intriqué dans
le dans mon discours pourquoi ça
marcherait pas de repasser par-dessus
puis d'ajouter les blagues je pense ça
se verrait ça ferait deux tons
différents enfin ça ferait forcer tu
vois après tu dis ça et puis parce que
j'essaie aussi d'ajouter des blagues
mais par rapport au niveau du tout
et c'est vrai qu'à chaque fois que je
repasse par dessus je ne trouve jamais
par contre si je trouve l'écriture là ça
marche ouais
ça fait partie du fil de penser quoi non
on peut partir on peut parler du côté
exclusif des blagues aussi peut-être
comment ça bah le les blagues en fait si
tu comprends pas la blague tu es exclu
d'office et du coup dans une vidéo de
vulgarisation ça peut enfin dans une
vidéo tout court ça peut un peu te
décourager de regarder la vidéo te dire
mais ça j'ai pas compris alors que c'est
même pas de la science que tu as pas
compris c'est juste une blague du coup
ouais faut doser ça aussi quoi et
comment tu le doses moi je n'ose pas du
tout
ça marche c'est ça non je fais vraiment
l'inverse exacte de ce qu'il faut faire
c'est à dire que non seulement je fais
des blagues que tout le monde peut
comprendre mais en plus je fais vraiment
des preuves avec jokes que même juste
moi je peux comprendre ah oui mais là tu
te mets des bâtons dans les rôles
non arrête c'est black on comprend pas
et tout juste j'ai des retours en mode
ah oui ça on comprend que c'est une
blague on comprend pas mais juste on se
dit c'est rigolo quoi mais donc j'ai
jamais eu de retour en disant c'est
c'est excluant exclusif exclu c'est à
dire que les gens qui se sentent exclus
sans probablement partie aussi ouais
c'est ça mais il pourrait venir me dire
wesh tu exagères quoi
donc c'est juste une hypothèse que j'ai
mais après la recherche sur les sciences
de l'humour et tout ça c'est quand même
que l'humour si tu comprends pas c'est
exclu quoi tout à fait bah c'est super
frustrant quand tout le monde rigole
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que quand tout
le monde rigole on est toujours là à
dire c'est quoi ouais c'est ça je veux
faire partie du groupe là expliquez-moi
donc tout à fait je comprends ou dans le
pire des cas tu le prends pour toi et
c'est encore pire quoi donc tu es sur
youtube il y a des vulgarisateurs il y a
des humoristes les vulgarisateurs à
ajouter toujours un petit peu de blagues
mais toi tu es vraiment à la frontière
entre les deux j'essaye tu essayes
est-ce que tu as des inspirations parce
que moi je connais que toi mais dans
cette frontière là
Alexandra si un petit peu qui a d'autres
si Max bird avec son spectacle et tout
tu l'as vu le spectacle ok moi j'ai pas
vu
justement le côté exercice après le fond
je juge pas je suis pas apte à juger
mais l'exercice d'en faire un stand-up
de faire des blagues et de faire passer
de la science quand même et de que l'un
cerve l'autre on va se communiquer
je trouve ça vraiment vraiment
intéressant et et ça marche hyper bien
quoi enfin le public était conquis donc
ouais ça vraiment en sortant de son
spectacle je me suis dit ah ouais ça
existe ça intéressant parce que pour le
coup Alexandre Astier les de ce que j'ai
vu de ces de ces spectacles genre sur la
physique quantique j'imagine que c'est
celui-là non tu parles parce que c'est
le c'est celui où il parle le plus de
science je pense où il y a de l'humour
il y avait pas attendu
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait c'était
vraiment une présentation et tout était
du comique de situation en fait ah oui
et du coup il y avait pas de de blagues
tu vois c'était juste rigolo parce que
on savait que c'était Alexandre Astier
qui était en train de se comporter comme
un comme un odieux prétentieux et donc
il y avait beaucoup qui étaient qui
passaient pas tant dans les paroles mais
dans la situation où on sentait qu'il y
avait un décalage tu vois et donc c'est
pour ça que je te mettrai pas la même
case non non mais c'était juste dans la
série des gens comme ça alors entre nous
entre nous j'ai pas trop aimé ce
spectacle je l'ai vu quand en vidéo j'ai
pas vu moi aussi je l'ai vu en vidéo
juste en fait c'est vraiment le trope du
prof et encore pire le prof méchant ça
me ça me crée en fait parce que c'est
trop vu et revu alors j'ai un problème
de vocabulaire le trope ouais je sais
pas j'avais envie de passer dans
Qu'est-ce que c'est le lieu commun de je
sais pas c'est pas du verlan ouais non
c'est un mot français petit aparté le
terme Trump fait bien référence un lieu
commun mais c'est un mot anglais en
français ça veut pas dire la même chose
donc ici on est sur la définition
anglaise du mot parce que en France tout
le monde met en verlan et puis moi comme
ça fait longtemps que j'habite plus en
France je ne comprends plus rien non non
il y a quelqu'un tout à l'heure qui a
dit la la MIF oui c'est la famille c'est
ça donc il a fallu que je demande la
traduction à quelqu'un c'est pas facile
donc
du prof donc oui et ça te ça te crée
peut-être à une époque où c'était pas
encore trop vu parce qu'il est pas
récent ce spectacle ouais je sais pas
même à l'époque quand je l'ai vu j'étais
ouais non mais et puis les gens qui
mettent des blouses blanches aussi
comment font des
faut arrêter ça il y en a plus trop
maintenant oui non non ça va c'est la
vague est passée je crois la vague est
passée je travaillais dans une dans une
émission de télé au Québec qui s'appelle
génial et tu avais une blouse et oui je
suis désolé Ah non mais je sais je
maîtrise c'est non mais j'étais
complètement d'accord pendant que
pendant l'émission mais l'émission elle
a je suis pas 13 ans puis à 13 ans
c'était ok maintenant tu peux pas
changer les costumes comme ça je pense
que l'animateur est tout à fait
conscient que la troupe la troupe là tu
m'as donné un nouveau mot maintenant je
le place au mauvais endroit que la
blouse n'a absolument aucun sens quoi
mais ça a fait bien quand on a toujours
pas compris ce que c'était la science ça
fait bien après c'est pas bien méchant
non plus quoi c'est pas le pire de c'est
pas le pire mais oui quand tu parlais
d'Alexandre assis avec le comique de
situation un truc que j'aime bien faire
c'est d'essayer de mélanger justement
les types du mot les types de comique
voilà pour que justement tout le monde
puisse en avoir pour son argent et même
si c'est gratuit et parce que j'aime
bien parce que quelqu'un peut aimer
l'humour absurde et ne pas aimer
l'humour noir et bah tant pis pour lui
est-ce qu'il y aura les deux tu vois
c'est pas mon message mais bref est-ce
que tu veux reprendre ta phrase pour
avoir un autre message non j'aime bien
comme ça ok d'accord c'est quoi ton type
d'humour préféré alors je crois l'humour
absurde j'aime bien quand même
et celui-là effectivement ou l'humour
malaisant entre guillemets ouais en vrai
ça c'est vraiment délicat parce que je
sais pas si je j'assumerai vraiment
enfin si j'assume vraiment de faire
passer cette humeur là parce que je suis
pas très fan en tant que public
ça c'est un problème effectivement c'est
vraiment difficile et du coup en vrai au
montage je coupe beaucoup de mes
silences malaisants parce que juste
c'est trop donc j'en laisse deux ou
trois mais en vrai au tournage j'en ai
genre 20 par vidéo quoi beaucoup trop
donc même toi tu arrives à Toto créer du
malaise
beaucoup
je trouve ça drôle quand même deux bah
ça que tu t'autocrines c'est bien parce
que comme ça ça me fait un petit un
petit policier dans la tête qui me dit
non là c'est trop là c'est trop et donc
tu doses finalement oui c'est vrai je
dose
j'ai un grand verre doseur mais je dose
quand même est-ce que tu en fais souvent
des vidéos c'est quand ton rythme oh là
là c'est terrible mais ça c'est parce
que tu fais d'autres choses tu enseignes
tu es sur le vortex je travaille
beaucoup avec Arte
le vortex on fait aussi des lives twitch
avec Marie de la boîte curiosité aussi
enfin on fait pas mal de trucs
effectivement je fais beaucoup de trucs
à côté les vidéos pour info mytho dont
je parlais aussi donc avec mes lampes
c'est une par mois voilà ça fait
beaucoup de choses à faire et du coup
sur ma chaîne de temps en temps je me
dis allez j'en fais une par mois et je
tiens deux mois donc je vais pas te dire
j'ai de fréquence parce que là j'ai rien
publié depuis genre quatre mois
peut-être donc je fais comme je peux
est-ce que tu as une liberté sur
l'écriture des autres vidéos quand c'est
pour d'autres médias oui oui bah j'ai un
mille en presse franchement meilleure
collaboration que j'ai jamais eu parce
que il me la scarte blanche il me laisse
faire toutes les blagues que je veux et
tout et c'est pour un public jeune en
plus donc c'est à moi de doser un peu
quand même mais genre ils sont là
derrière et il m'encourage dans mes
bêtises la dernière vidéo que j'ai
enregistré je me suis déguisé en Mario
et et voilà c'est rigolo je pense j'ai
vu une photo de passe une passer une
photo de toi en Mario justement bah
voilà c'était hier ça donc est-ce que tu
fais attention à ce que tu es blagues et
ton contenu soit du couple donc tu fais
attention ça tu fais ça sur ta chaîne
aussi ou pas j'essaie de faire ça sur ma
chaîne d'une manière un peu bizarre
c'est à dire que je peux laisser des
blagues horribles mais j'évite de dire
des gros mots
donc à la limite les blagues horribles
ils peuvent juste ne pas comprendre et
demander à leurs parents à leurs parents
t'inquiète et juste pas mettre de gros
mots voilà c'est un truc que j'avais pas
réalisé mais j'ai rencontré justement
des personnes qui connaissaient si la
bus ce matin parce qu'on est au festival
Friends et qui me disait qu'ils avaient
des enfants de 3 et 7 ans je crois donc
en tout cas dans cette gamme là gamme
d'âge là et il me disait l'avantage avec
syllabus c'est que on n'a pas besoin de
regarder avant pour savoir si on peut
mettre devant nos enfants parce que tu
mets jamais de gros mots et puis il y a
beaucoup de vulgarisateurs qu'on aime
bien mais on filtre certaines vidéos
parce qu'il y a des gros mots et j'avais
jamais réalisé parce que c'est pas
quelque chose de si conscient que ça de
ma part tu vois de pas mettre de gros
mots en tout cas c'est pas une c'est
juste que j'ai pas de gros mots à dire
donc voilà tout simplement ça n'arrivera
rarement et
donc c'est une dimension que j'avais pas
réalisée donc toi c'est volontaire il
faut que c'est un effort de ta part de
ne pas mettre de gros mots c'est pas un
effort mais disons que c'est un je suis
vigilante et si jamais il y en a un qui
se grippe qui se glisse dans mon script
et ben je le vire et si jamais au
tournage et ben j'essaye de refaire une
prise puis on verra après
occasionnellement il y en a des fois il
y en a dans les sous-titres parce que ça
aussi j'en avais mis dans un script et
je l'ai pas dit au tournage et en fait
j'ai uploé le script tel quel en tant
que sous-titre et il y a une vidéo qui
est vraiment
elle est fournie
donc ne regardez pas les sous-titres
avec vos enfants mais voilà du coup
j'essaye de faire attention quoi ok
parce que est-ce que c'est important
pour toi de rejoindre une audience plus
jeune ou est-ce que c'est juste que
c'est ton image ou c'est pour quelle
raison en fait ouais parce que j'aime
bien le principe de vulgariser pour tous
les âges et alors je fais pas enfin
c'est pas
ostensiblement un truc pour pour enfants
mais si ça peut être regardé par les
jeunes ça me va aussi il y a un festival
où j'étais le dernier le plaisir à Nice
et je peux dire que tous les gens qui
sont venus me voir ils avaient moins de
15 ans j'ai même c'est vrai oui j'ai
même eu deux petits adorables qui
avaient genre 8 et 10 ans qui sont
mortes ah on adore tes vidéos et tout
j'étais trop sont trop fière c'est fou
ça mais oui parce que j'aurais pas dit
que tes vidéos étaient pour un public si
jeune que ça normalement plus mais
écoute comme quoi comme quoi c'est ça
qui est c'est une question qui revient
souvent quand je dis tout le temps il
faut déterminer son public et tout et
puis sur le web comment tu détermines
ton public bah chaque fois je réponds
maintenant dans la tête et puis
peut-être que c'est pas exactement lui
que tu toucheras mais au moins tu en as
en tête c'est ça que tu te rends compte
que bah il est beaucoup plus large que
ce que tu penses que d'où l'utilité
d'ajuster après moi j'ai eu un petit
aussi hier qui avait eu prendre une
photo avec moi mon dieu mais tu as quel
âge incroyable ok on va faire une photo
pas de problème
trop cool mais c'est cool c'est ça fait
plaisir de voir que on est qu'on est
plus universel qu'on croit ouais c'est
ça et puis je sais pas c'est vraiment un
job où tu te dis que ça a du sens en
fait quand ça touche les enfants c'était
ainsi mon terme j'espère que ça vous a
plu si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas à
aller noter et liker sur la plateforme
sur laquelle vous l'écoutez ainsi qu'à
le partager évidemment on se retrouve
dans deux semaines pour un nouvel
épisode bye
[Musique]